>> Laura: WE JUST FINISHED
COVERING SOME OF THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL WINDS OF THE YEAR, BUT
NOW IT'S TIME TO TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE WORST MOMENTS.
BACK WITH US, AND ARI FLEISCHER
AND STEPHEN MILLER, ARE
GENTLEMEN, WE BEGIN WITH THIS
NOBLE LIST.
THE JANUARY 6TH HEARING TOP IT
OFF.
SO DESPERATE, WHERE THEY COULD
CREATE DRAMA, THAT THEY GAVE AT
THE HOLLYWOOD TREATMENT.
AND LITERALLY GIVE IT THE
HOLLYWOOD TREATMENT.
THE COMMITTEE BROUGHT IT UP FOR
METICULOUS EXECUTIVES TO TRY TO
PRODUCE THESE HEARINGS, AND THAT
MET THE REGGIE MEDIA HAD TO DO
ITS BEST TO KEEP UP.
>> NOW, AFTER A YEAR OF WORKING
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
THE RESULT OF THE INSURRECTION
INVESTIGATION, THEY ARE ABOUT TO
BE REVEALED.
♪ ♪
>> RIGHT NOW THE NATION'S FOCUS
RETURNS TO THE U.S. CAPITOL TO
AWAIT THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
ACCOUNT YET COMMITTED AGAINST
UNITED STATES AND THE SACRED
GROUND.
>> OKAY, THIS WHOLE THING WAS
KIND OF A REVENGE PLAY, BECAUSE
IT ENDED UP BEING USED BY,
PEOPLE LIKE CHENEY, TO BE TRYING
KIND OF PROP UP WHAT ENDED UP
BEING A DIME POLITICAL CAREER,
AND LET'S GO TO YOU -- STEPHEN,
RIGHT NOW TO ME, THIS SEEMS LIKE
IT IS ALMOST A PARODY OF ITSELF.
WHERE THIS ALL IT UP, FOR MAKING
CRIMINAL REFERS TO THE DOJ IS A
SERIOUS MATTER.
>> WELL, IT IS A SERIOUS MATTER.
BUT AS A PRACTICAL MATTER, IT
ACTUALLY UNDERMINES ANYTHING
THAT WILL HELP TO ACHIEVE BY
MAKING THIS WHOLE THING EVEN
MORE TRANS MATT LEO POLITICAL
THAT HAS BEEN FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND MANY LEGAL ANALYSTS
WOULD AGREE WITH THAT STATEMENT.
BUT ALL THOSE CLIPS YOU PLAY
SHOWING THAT THEY TREATED THIS
LIKE A HOME FROM THERE.
LIKE A NEW INDIANA JONES FILM.
THIS WHOLE THING IS A GIANT
PARODY OF DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS,
A PARODY OF THE MEDIA,
APPARENTLY OF THE WHOLE RULING
CLASS WHILE PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING
FROM FOOD THEY CANNOT AFFORD.
CRYING THEY CANNOT DEAL WITH, OF
CARTELS WERE RAVAGING OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH DEADLY DRUGS
BUT ALL THEIR FOCUS ON ARE THE
SAME WITCH HUNT, THE SAME
PERSECUTION THEY'VE BEEN
ENGAGING IN FOR YEARS, IN THIS
COUNTRY IS PLEADING WITH
EVERYONE FOR THE LOVE OF GOD IF
WE COULD PLEASE FOCUS ON THE
THINGS THAT AFFECT OUR LIVES.
IN OUR CHILDREN.
IN OUR FAMILIES.
THEY ARE READY TO FINALLY DO
THAT AND HOPEFULLY THAT TO
HAPPEN IN A FEW DAYS.
WHEN HOUSE REPUBLICANS TAKE
HOUSE.
>> RA, IT IS QUITE STUDYING TO
SEE THESE IMAGES FROM THE
BORDER.
THAT ARE JUST -- IT JUST TAKES
YOUR BREATH AWAY AT EVERY LEVEL.
AND YEAH, A REFERRAL, AND I HAVE
READ THROUGH THIS, IT WAS KIND
OF B.S. TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH.
THE COUNTRY, IS GETTING OVERRUN.
WE HAVE ABOUT 18 MILLION PEOPLE
THAT COULD BE HERE BY THE TIME
BIDEN COMES OUT OF OFFICE.
AND IT IS DONALD TRUMP'S WHO
THEIR OBSESSED WITH.
AND THEY ADMITTED THIS.
>> I MEAN PEOPLE CRITICIZE
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR THE THINGS
HE'S SAYS, SUCH AS WHAT HE SAID
ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION.
THE THINGS THAT DEMOCRATS DO.
THAT ARE VIOLATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
THERE ARE VIOLATION OF THE RULE
OF LAW, NEED TO STEP ON THE
BORDER BORDER THAT WE CAN
ABANDON WOOD OF LAW.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
APPROACH IS TO JUST DELIVERY OF
THE BODY IN.
AND THE REASON THEY DO IT LAURA,
I THINK THEY WANT TO HAVE
AMERICANS WHO ARE THINKERS AND
UP VOTE DEMOCRATIC IF THEY CAN
ONLY BECOME CITIZENS.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE DOING THIS.
IT IS NOT HUMANITARIAN IF IT WAS
HUMANITARIAN AND THEY WOULDN'T
LET THIS HAPPEN WITH PEOPLE
WOULD NOT PUT THEIR LIVES IN THE
HANDS OF SMUGGLERS.
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, IS ONE OF THE GREATEST
MORAL AND LEGAL TRAGEDIES THAT
COULD EVER UPSET OUR COUNTRY AND
NOT TO MENTION THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE FOOLED INTO THINKING THAT
THEY CAN COME HERE FLOODING
AMERICA THE WAY THAT THEY ARE.
AND WHO ARE THE LOSERS?
MOSTLY AMERICANS WORKING CLASS.
THIS IS AN ABANDONMENT OF THE
RULE OF LAW WITH THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND IS DELIVERED.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE WITH
THINGS.
>> I MEAN, IT TAKES YOUR BREATH
AWAY.
AND I'M SPEECHLESS, IT IS SO
OUTRAGEOUS.
BUT TO WRAP UP THIS OF WORSE, WE
FELT WE COULD ASK BOTH OF HIS
HAND OF A FEW DISHONORABLE
MENTIONS.
NOW, LET'S START WITH THE
OVERALL WORST OF THE YEAR, THE
EVENT WHO IS THE COVETED AWARD
IN YOUR MIND?
GMAC WELL, WERE RIGHT ON TOPIC
HERE BECAUSE IT IS SAFE FOR
TERRY MYRICK LOVE DHS.
EVERYTHING -- THIS MAN IS
ALLOWED CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS,
TO RUN FREE IN OUR BORDER.
SUPPORTERS AND OUR CHILDREN, TO
SABOTAGE HER WORKING CLASS, TO
DESTROY HEALTH CARE SYSTEM IN
THE PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM.
OUR FINANCIAL SYSTEM.
THE TRUST IN OUR COUNTRY, IT
ISN'T THE, ONE OF THE GREAT
MORAL LEGAL TRAVIS THEIS IN THE
HISTORY OF NOT JUST OUR COUNTRY,
BUT ANY COUNTRY.
AND I WISH THAT WE WERE HERE
TODAY AND A HINT TO A RISK OF
PEOPLE GOING GENTLY INTO THAT
GOOD NIGHT, AND LEADING US
ALONG, AND STOP THINK IS ENDLESS
ASSAULT ON THE LOSSES SOMEBODY
OF OUR COUNTRY, BUT INSTEAD IS
GONNA BE UP TO THE HOUSE G.O.P.
TO IMPEACH HIM.
>> RA RA JAKE STONE, WHO IS YOUR
WORSE FOR THE YEAR QUICKLY.
>> MINUS VLADIMIR PUTIN, THE
INVASION OF UKRAINE, THE
HORRIFIC BARBARIC STYLE EXACTLY
WHAT THEY DID IN SYRIA WHERE
THEY'D ATTACKED CIVILIANS AND
BOMB BUILDINGS AND KILLED PEOPLE
AND DESTROYED ENERGY, THIS IS
ONE OF THAT MAYOR PETE PUT IT IS
DUE IN THE UKRAINE RIGHT NOW IT
IS OF MODERN DAY ABERRATION --
ABOMINATION OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
A WAR CRIMINAL IS THERE ONE.
>> WELL, DID YOU MAKE YOUR LIST,
BECAUSE HE HAS A SLATE OF
CANDIDATES AND THE THE WAR.
>> LAUREL, ACTUALLY CAN SEE A
TIE HERE BETWEEN VLADIMIR PUTIN
AND JIM PAYNE THE PRESIDENT FOR
CHINA, AND MOSTLY BECAUSE A
COVID.
THEY LIED TO THE WILL OF THE
BUCKLE THERE, THEY STILL ALIGNED
TO THE WORLD ABOUT KOBY PERRY
YOU SEE THAT THEY ARE CLAIMING
THAT THEY HAD ANY HARDLY ANY
DEATH IN CHINA, AND THEY STILL
WOULD NOT TELL THE TRUTH.
THEY HATE IT WHEN IT TOOK PLACE
THEY DID NOT COOPERATE WITH US
WHEN IT BROKE OUT.
IN A DISTILLERS CHINA WHICH IS
NOT COME AROUND TO HIS PROPER
PLACE IN THE WORLD.
>> RA, A